the president's likeness is everywhere
across turkey
recep tayyip erdogan saying thank you
for his re-election
which has made him an almost
all-powerful head of state
addon is now president party leader and
head of government
rolled into one he can hire fire
ministers and some senior judges
to solve parliament and rule by decree
his powers are virtually unchecked
but one thing hasn't changed he's
running a bitterly divided country and
that is particularly evident
here in istanbul the district of essen
love for example is an erdogan
stronghold
most of those living here are pious and
conservative
almost 70 percent voted in favor of the
president
and people are happy that he remains in
charge
he's a source of pride for us he
represents us well on the world stage
he's our leader
our president has done what needs to be
done so far
and i am sure he knows what the path
forward is
we've been so happy since the elections
our country is going to make huge
progress and god willing our future is
going to be bright
views in the karikou district are very
different
many young people live here students
artists
most of them oppose erdogan the prospect
of him ruling for at least another term
scares them
a whole generation grew up under erwan
it's going to be another five years
and i'm sure after that another five
years he's imposing his education system
his ideology on us that's not good
he's not my president i see a dark
future
we don't know what to do we have no hope
[Music]
i'm too tired of talking about democracy
we still know what it is but will our
children
the problems that turkey faces are far
from over
surging inflation high youth
unemployment
the war in neighboring syria the
president has promised a solution for
all these issues
but his biggest challenge after all may
be how to reconcile
a deeply polarized society